qu'adviendra-t-il des sanctions
américaines contre l'iran si l'élection
de joe biden est confirmée téhéran est
dans l'expectative
pour rappel en mai 2010huit donald trump
s'était retirée unilatéralement de
l'accord de vienne de 2015 qui visait à
contrôler le nucléaire iranien
en sortant de ce pacte il a de nouveau
imposé de lourdes sanctions économiques
à téhéran qui ont plongé l'économie du
pays dans une sévère récession
les tensions sont encore montée d'un
cran à la mi septembre dernier quand
washington a décidé de maintenir ces
sanctions invoquant un soutien de l'onu
que les autres membres du conseil de
sécurité compte est un durcissement non
suivie par les pays européens ce qui a
provoqué l'ire de l'administration 30
pays qui est isolé aujourd'hui ce ne
sont pas les états unis mais plutôt
l'iran par ses actions nous avons montré
très clairement que chaque état membre
des nations unies a la responsabilité
d'appliquer ces sanctions ce qui inclut
assurément le royaume uni la france et
l'allemagne
nous attendons à ce que ces pays
appliquent ces sanctions
cette décision avait pourtant isoler un
peu plus donald trump sur la scène
internationale à moins de deux mois de
la présidentielle ce week end à
l'annoncé des résultats donnant joe
biden vainqueur le gouvernement iranien
se réjouit mais reste prudent le futur
gouvernement américain a maintenant une
occasion de se rattraper après les
erreurs passées et de revenir sur la
voie de l'adhésion aux engagements
internationaux et au respect du droit
international
le peuple américain a parlé et le monde
regarde si les nouveaux dirigeants vont
abandonner la politique de harcèlement
désastreuse et illégale du régime
sortant et accepteront le
multilatéralisme la coopération et le
respect de la loi
ce qui compte le plus pour l'iran ce
sont les actes dignité intérêts et
diplômes acier responsable car la
position de joe biden sur ce sujet
restent timorés dans un article publié
dans la revue foreign policy il ya six
mois il déroulé son pro
rama l'international et évoqué le cas
iranien sans pour autant adopter de
position claire l'accord nucléaire
historique avec l'iran que
l'administration obama biden a négocié à
empêcher l'iran de se doter d'une arme
nucléaire
pourtant trump a précipitamment rejeté
l'accord incitant l'iran a redémarré son
programme nucléaire et à devenir plus
provocateur augmentant le risque d'une
autre guerre désastreuse dans la région
téhéran doit revenir au strict respect
de l'accord s'il le fait je rejoindrai
l'accord et utiliserez notre engagement
renouvelé envers la diplomatie pour
travailler avec nos alliés dans le but
de le renforcer et de l'étendre tout en
repoussant plus efficacement les autres
activités déstabilisante de l'iran à
téhéran aussi les habitants restent
partagés avec le départ de tromper
l'arrivée de bail donne la situation
s'est un peu améliorée dans le dollar et
le prix de l'or gérard résultat les
choses sont plus calmes
si dieu le veut et les choses iraient
encore mieux pour nous le peuple iranien
c'est vrai by donne est beaucoup mieux
en termes de personnalité il cela ne
fait toujours pas de différence pour
l'iran cela peut être bon pour eux mais
pas pour l'iran la presse iranienne
aussi est dubitative ce dimanche le
quotidien conservateur ressalat titre
l'ennemi sans masque est parti l'ennemi
masqué est arrivé al'inverse le journal
réformateur sharks affirme en une il y a
clairement une différence entre bayonne
et run quoi qu'il en soit il faudra bien
que la république islamique compose avec
le nouveau locataire
c'est à la maison blanche